you uh just mentioned that you thought
oh i'm sorry that you you just mentioned
biden apparently is going to go harder
on big tech
these are all the articles yeah that i
was looking at you were seeing it so
here's something funny that's happening
right now
techcrunch reports youtube is testing
hiding dislike
counts on videos i wonder why that might
be
yeah could it be that every single video
that joe biden puts out or that
democrats put out
are just slammed by everyone that's
democracy now what is that
is it a russian bot conspiracy
that people are saying i don't like this
video from joe biden my question is
where are then the democrats to
counteract that and give an upvote to
joe biden they don't exist
no you don't you know what it is they're
still downloading trump's content i
think
the people who vote for joe biden don't
pay attention don't watch the news have
no idea what's going on
and they're not going to watch a joe
biden video the trump supporters the
conservatives the moderates the people
who are quote unquote red pilled who
have
woken up to the media's lies in the
narrative it's because they're looking
at videos of trump they're watching the
source material on youtube and then
going
i don't like this so youtube now has to
intervene and remove the dislike button
counter
it's a matter of time until they remove
the live
views counter as well because there are
times that they are streaming the
the biden giving remarks at the white
house or even during the campaign
uh biden is gonna sit down with these
activists and you would see in the
bottom left corner
800 people are watching 900 people are
watching
people would circle it and tweet it and
say is this a joke like this is the
the president the most popular president
900 people watching this video and i'm
one of them
right now but listen listen democrats
have always gone
for low information voters and a lot of
people might be like oh here we go
tim paul so biased against democrats
he's right wing no
actually i'm pretty far left politically
it's kind of strange
my problem is you're not going to get me
to say something that's not true all
right i'll tell you something
democrats want to give the right of to
they want 16 year olds to have the right
to vote whoa
16 year olds you are not going to
convince me are high information voters
some maybe but as you get younger and
younger
the likelihood of finding a low
information voter goes up
exponentially 16 to young people no but
i but 16 year olds are also eating tide
pods yeah
right no offense to 16 year olds
but
we can allow the 16 year old to vote if
the 16 year olds can also
buy alcohol buy cigarettes and get
drafted because what i have a problem
with when it comes to these age things
isn't i
doing still enjoy my cigarettes every
now and then
right you got to be 21 to smoke now in a
lot of states 18 to get a beer
but the 16 year old can vote you off to
war in afghanistan and you're like
wait a second so what is the age of
adulthood and make
everything that age i don't know what
parents tell them
what if what if the requirement for
voting was just you have to
live on uh you have to have you no
longer
maybe it has to be a job maybe the
requirements are you have a job you have
to be paying taxes yeah you pay taxes
you can vote well
taxation requires representation you
should have to have some sort of skin in
the game right
i mean the original constitution was was
they argued about landowners and that
was considered
you know offensive or however you want
to phrase it um but
the idea was skin in the game and if you
are i'm sorry if
this is the the problem that romney got
into back in 12 when he talked about the
44 percent and we don't 47. i think it
was
and and he phrased it terribly but i
think the point he meant to say was
there's a large population of this of
this population of this country
that is on the taking side and so they
will vote
for things to be given to them for free
whether it's stimulus checks
whether it's welfare whether it's free
look at the people voting for free uh
you know a absolution of their college
loans well i didn't go to college i
don't have any debt
right but but you did and you got a
degree in modern dance and i have to now
pay
welcome my personal life exactly right
so so there is going to be
always a class of people that will vote
for more free stuff for themselves
totally what it does
it has to be skin in the game exactly
that's why kids shouldn't vote just
just to bring it back the ultimate point
is democrats like voters who are
on the low information side yet at the
same time these are the same people who
claim to be
more educated i'm sorry i need to
explain something everybody's listening
going to college does not mean you are
more educated i i mean that
and a lot of people confuse going to
university with
being educated you can spend four years
in college and read almost
nothing and just you know squeeze on by
party hard party hard and just do the
bare minimum
or you could be someone who goes to the
library every day
and reads reads a book every day and
you're substantially more educated than
somebody who just decides to go to
college now
i think there's a correlation between
getting an education and being in
college but in the past
generation or so college seems to be a
big fat waste of time it used to be a
huge opportunity to
have access to books and and stuff but
you don't need that the internet now
yeah yeah if i can go online and learn
whatever i want what's the point of
spending 40 50 grand for it
i will say though if we if we think
about this from a solution-oriented
perspective
maximizing the best outcome for this
country i do believe we need some form
of student loan forgiveness
probably in the form of eliminating
interest rates and at this point saying
pay off your principal you borrow the
money you got to pay it back
maybe maybe within with with inflation
as a
as a standard you know uh interest rate
not
compounded interest or anything like
that but i will point out too for a lot
of these people
on the left who are like we should have
our student loans forgiven
that would be and this is what they
don't understand giving a 50
000 grant to the wealthiest americans
yeah fund the rich so i wanted that what
they want to do
i wanted to google this before i talked
about it and some of the largest
endowments in
american university systems harvard has
over 40 billion dollars in endowment
so if you want to talk about student
loan absolution why doesn't harvard kick
in some of their 40
billion dollars which literally just
accrues interest every year they charge
these people
thousand dollars a year yale has what is
it twenty seven billion dollars
uh yeah sorry thirty billion dollars
stanford 27 princeton 25
mit 17. so if we want to talk about
student loan forgiveness
obviously there has to be reform of the
tuition system because it is being paid
for by the taxpayers
but why doesn't harvard give up some of
their damn money
to pay those guys who have useless i
mean quite honestly
if you have a graduate degree in
critical race theory from harvard
you have a useless degree i'd like to
give a shout out to our good friend will
chamberlain and say
seize the endowments when you say
endowments is that the yearly
like government gives them 30 billion a
year no this is uh you know rich people
who write a 100 million dollar check and
they want to
endow a a a chair in their name or they
want to endow a building or whatever
but harvard's been around for 200 and
something years and they've accrued over
time so that's money sitting in an
account
exactly literally sitting in the bank
just the other day georgetown announced
they got a 100 million dollar grant from
somebody
i i forget who 100 million dollar
donation georgetown's going to take that
100 billion
they're going to put it in the bank
they're not going to drop the tuition
rate for any of their students a dime
they're just going to put it in the bank
and say thank you very much
for your money what i can't understand i
know we were supposed to be talking
about youtube
dislike count but i think it's all
related it is i i really do think so
i think that these these people who go
to university think about it for two
seconds
they're told to do it not everybody i
know a lot of you listening probably
went to college you didn't realize it
but there's a lot of people who are like
what should i do and then someone comes
along and says
you're gonna take out fifty thousand
dollars worth of loans don't worry
you have to do it everybody has to do it
and they go okay i'll do what you say
and they go to college they do as
they're told they rack up all this debt
now they're living in this massive debt
doing as they're told every step of the
way and they're miserable
some people finally realize what's going
on
they'll drop out they'll leave or
they'll realize it after the fact hey
wait a minute that was a big mistake
i screwed myself up by not listening to
myself
now you look at these people these
college educated they say
overwhelmingly vote for for democrats
correlation between those
who don't investigate who don't watch
a biden's speech to see what he actually
has to say and don't watch a trump
speech to see what he has to say
and thus the only people who are
watching bite another people who
actually listen to what he has to say
don't like it hit the dislike button and
then youtube decides well we got to
remove it because it's making us look
good
you've come full circle absolutely i
love that yeah no
no you're absolutely right and and when
you get into the college level the way
youtube is removing content
the way universities are removing
content that they don't like the way
they're banning certain clubs banning
certain speakers
heck it wasn't that long ago that people
like ann coulter tried to speak at
berkeley
that it looked like the minnesota riots
and you say
you or you are not being sent off to
d-day right
but you 19-year-old boy can't handle the
fact that a woman whose commentary you
don't like is on your campus
just you know what man up and stay in
your dorm room and say wow that's too
bad i mean that's what i do when a
baseball team is on that i don't like
all the red sox are on tonight well i'm
not gonna watch the damn channel
right so so not only are they not
exposed to this stuff but it's being
banned from it proactively banned
and on top of that the political stuff
we're banning certain authors now we're
ben not
dr seuss but we're banning parts of
shakespeare there was that op-ed a
little while ago about the like
the undeniable whiteness of shakespeare
or something absurd like that
and you say i don't even think
shakespeare knew he was white because it
was the 1520s in england
he just knew he was shakespeare and and
were banning those types of
who was the dude uh from braveheart that
movie's based off of
william wallace yeah i think someone
graffitied a wall in like scotland
saying william wallace wallace was
racist or something
and someone commented i'm pretty sure he
never even saw a black person in his
entire life no i guarantee you he never
did
yeah right i mean it was it was 12 12 uh
13th century yeah you know dude
everybody was racist back then
that was when you were all well they
were more like um xenophobic
yeah afraid of the other yeah because
the the last people they knew who didn't
look like them were the vikings and they
killed everybody and they stole all
their church goods and they stole all
the women
well exactly so take a look at
scandinavia now
oh yeah what happened in that place i
don't know what they oh
they received too many immigrants
they're like the whoa no no no i i don't
think this was immigration
like you know what's really fascinating
is that i mentioned this the other day
think about illegal immigrants right now
coming to the u.s
they're willing to climb mountains ride
on top of trains
make it through 90 miles of desert with
limited supplies because they believe in
that american dream
and look i can respect that that's drive
but you got to come in the proper way
for a variety of reasons we don't want
people going through the desert risking
their lives
and we want to make sure that when they
come here they're they're given real
opportunities if they just come in they
get exploited and it creates whole
you know a lot of problems economically
for many of the migrants
but you take a look at some of these
countries even the united states
the popula it's the it's the it's the uh
domestic population
uh mostly suburban progressives and
liberals
that have become just absolutely weak
and pathetic
you take a look at scandinavia and it is
the overwhelmingly
white uh you know indigenous
of the of the region i suppose you'd
call them who are opening up all these
policies that will erode and eventually
destroy their own their own governments
and i'm speaking specifically about like
you know swede
sweden's policy on their welfare system
for instance is unsustainable unless
they keep bringing in more and more
migrants
now that's not what i'm referring to
that's actually them trying to stem the
bleed
the problem is they wouldn't need to
desperately ask people to come to their
country
if their country was properly run but
you look back at the viki
the vikings they got on boats they went
to england
they stole all them and came back and
they were brutal the vikings were brutal
all the really hot women yeah that's
right
that's why apparently they're so
attractive well i was
i was told this joke when i was in uh i
i think i was told this joke every every
i was in norway sweden and denmark
and they're like you want to hear a
scandinavian joke why are there no
beautiful women in in england
and i'm like why because we stole them
all and i'm like it's a really amazing
joke
for a group of people that are like some
of the most demure and like
you know uh i guess i don't want to weak
willed i suppose docile
seem very calm maybe they're in the cold
all the time so they move slower that's
because socialism
socialism ultimately will is in a feat a
system
and it will it will emasculate you i
mean i just think that's the root and
social
they have been solved socialists for
generations now look and i think
ultimately as a
is it is a defeatist philosophy and it
is a a
weakening philosophy and i think that's
what you get after
you know three generations of
quasi-socialists that's what happens to
you
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you